foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
come right down here
and it's like a legal pass to do
whatever you want any type of drug you
want any advice you have
uh come here to do it you're not gonna
get in trouble you know that's that's
that's basically what's put out there by
by law enforcement by City officials
um you see the chaos that's going around
you're going to see people blood running
down their arm needles in their neck
needle in their arm piping their mouth
um
it's everything goes out here
[Music]
Ground Zero of our local heroin epidemic
lies in the heart of Philadelphia's
Kensington section Kensington the drugs
were the motive for a shooting in
Kensington this morning they're drug
users from all over line the streets and
makeshift area in Kensington about this
Haven for drug addicts Don heroin in
Kensington round zero for Philadelphia's
Irwin epidemic he's on the front lines
of the nation's heroin epidemic with
evidence of battles lost scattered like
weeds Nets big results in Kensington
struggling with drug addiction May soon
have a place to safely inject themselves
drug abuse in Kensington is just not
hard to find opioid crisis is far from
over
all right
it's sad it's crazy
it's crazy
[Applause]
foreign
look look you see where you're at
so that's that's a normal occurrence
um people get high wander into traffic
it's 100 getting worse and it's gonna
get worse tomorrow and the next day is
going to be even worse and the next day
is going to be even worse
we're trying to combat opiates we're not
dealing with opiates no more that game
is done you know that ship has has gone
on sale
you're you're literally dealing with
chemical warfare you know that's what's
happening you see the people falling
apart uh limbs falling off you've seen
Duffy when we was down there his arm it
looks like a zombie movement you know
that's what you're seeing with the
xylazine
and the track is is everybody laying
face down on the ground that's what the
trunk is
xylazine is a tranquilizer it's meant
for cattle for horses
um
it's not meant for human consumption so
when people shoot it up you see the the
sores it starts and it's just looking
for the easiest way out of the body and
it presents itself in the stores
um the trunk is we're not seeing those
same uh ulcers and and skin abrasions
but what you're seeing is the the quick
overdoses
so when people are being dosed with
Narcan to being helped from an overdose
the Narcan does nothing to affect the
train
it's the worst thing I've ever seen you
know this is literally chemical warfare
and we'll realize that once we start
playing around with these chemicals
we're gonna lose